[Music]
thank you
all right great to be in New York thank
you everyone for coming over and having
a look at all of our new stuff
all right let's get started
so yeah uh you guys heard the news and
you probably not only heard the news you
guys write the news so you know there's
not great news lately about VC industry
and
I'm getting going really great
um but really interesting thing here is
that despite the industry Trend we are
actually doing really well and uh you
know that the PC industry is dominated
by some really big corporations that are
like 100 years old we're much smaller
younger and agile company and we have a
lot of really cool Innovative products
and that's what really sets us apart and
that's also how we're able to Buck the
trend and do well even when the oval
situation is maybe not great so that's
really what it matters that you have
Innovative products that you have
products that have more value and that
deliver something that other products
don't right when there's pressure on the
market that's when people pay attention
to it and go for those products and
that's that's why we're able to back the
track
so you can see that
um in a lot of markets uh we are doing
really well at Big Milestones so you can
see that in gaming which is a part of
our consumer laptops right
um we are doing really well in several
markets and regular consumer laptops who
are also doing really well at several
markets and we're able to not only keep
our market share but even grow despite
these These Times so covet has rocked
the boat all right we all saw the supply
chain
um has swung back and forth and that's
exactly the scenario where we benefit
um from having all these great
Innovative products
[Music]
that takes a little bit Yeah I think you
skipped the slide but it's okay
so
um in our consumer laptops besides
gaming we have three different brands
right we have Pro art which is our
high-end NATO brand we have our zenbooks
and we have our Diva books and example
can see uh what I'm going to talk about
here today the latest from our demos
there it is so our sandbox are Ultra
portable slim and light laptops and uh
yeah so I'll give you a quick rundown of
the most interesting new stuff namely
this example guest routine which you
guys have seen we have it all over the
place here
um and I'll quickly quickly walk you
through what's really cool and new and
exciting about it all right
so yeah Zenbook overall as our laptop
brand
um stands for several things
um it's our those are portable brand so
it's really thin and like all metal
chassis
um sustainability is something that's
you that we started to really focus on
that we announced at CS thinking of this
year
um so we focus on as much eco-friendly
Technologies as possible we're going big
on EP gold for those of you who are not
familiar with EP it's essentially
certifying that all your supply chain is
sustainable not just you yourself but
all the suppliers and vendors that you
work with and we have a brand new plasma
ceramic aluminum which is a really
really nice premium material you can
have it feel because the special thing
about it is not just how it looks but
also how it feels we have it over there
behind the tree and uh OLED laptops are
a really big deal for Samsung for
Consumer and laptops we use Samsung OLED
panels for the last two years now and
are doing really well there when it
comes to market share as well we are now
calling in Asus Lumina Outlet I'll talk
a little bit more about what that means
later and we now guarantee a Delta e
below one which I'm sure a lot of you
guys would have been really happy about
it and next one
powerful it's a performance that's
something that our zenbooks have always
stood out in as well we tend to put more
cores and higher tdps and more
performance into those ultra slim
portable laptops than the next guy and
that's something that really stands out
when you compare the similar form
factors similar dimensions of the laptop
with something else that's on the market
okay and here it is the Zenbook s13 OLED
so we had a Zenbook escort team in 2022
last year that was very popular
especially a lot of amateurs really love
that laptop unfortunately it was not
super widespread and not super available
but people are really happy about this
product and we have a much improved
version this year that's even better so
it's significantly lighter and of course
my science
yeah portable right so what makes it
super portable it's only one centimeter
in thickness and it weighs only one kill
so that's a really really crazy model so
when you think about Ultra portable
laptops it is possible to go better than
this and lighter than this but it's
getting to the point of diminishing
returns right Mike yes stopping or is it
something with layers
all right okay we'll just keep going
and how did we manage to achieve this
it's not like there's one part in the
laptop that you can just make thinner
and then the whole laptop becomes
Slimmer um and it's not like a laptop is
a sandwich where every layer lies on top
of the next layer but they're all kind
of like intertwined if you think about
it and we had to make all of these
different pieces thinner to be able to
make the Toby laptop this sick so it's
around five millimeters thinner than the
2022 model that one was around 50
millimeters and now we brought it down
to around 10 million to 10 millimeters
so you can see the webcam is 0.8
millimeters thinner the laptop is 0.15
millimeter Center so those are all
really small numbers but that's what you
have to do because it all adds up that's
how you get to those big uh stay savings
as you do little pieces everywhere and
when really sets apart design book s13
is there's other Ultra books in the
market that are really thin and light
but they usually come with compromises
and pretty big ones if not go through
why we didn't really and how we achieve
to not only compromise on all these
things
all right
so these are the lower parts of the labs
you see motherboard the center the fans
the cooling system the center the
batteries that are attached pad the
keyboard and the bottom case so all of
these pieces are set
Ting and what you would expect what a
lot of these laptops to trade-off wise
is the build quality battery life the
keyboard the i o and so on but not with
us so if you go to the next Slide
the webcam so I pointed out the webcam
is thinner than the one in the previous
year's model so we'd expect that maybe
the webcam quality isn't as great as the
previous one but no the webcast quality
is actually better if you go to the next
slide you can see that the image is
higher resolution it's brighter they
have a dedicated IR sensor we have a
dedicated ambient light sensor
um and we are able to do it through all
of that even though the webcam module is
different and for those of you who are
not aware the webcam is actually a big
part of the the factor that defines the
thickness of the lid so you can make the
rest of the lid display center the
webcam is really the challenging part
particularly the lens that you need on
the webcam and we have the different
bits and pieces here as well he looked
behind me you can actually look at the
different parts and we have a
side-by-side comparison of the 2022 and
the 2023 and you can see uh if you have
a nice camera that you're able to do
macro shots this is where it's going to
shine and do some awesome micro shot
starting when you see the difference
between uh the 2022 and 2023 model
next up
um the aluminum chassis so we made the
chassis itself thinner but the Palm rest
is actually sturdier and flexes less
than the previous one that's not to say
that the 2022 s13 was Wally that was
already pretty sturdy but the new one is
thinner and sturdier
the touchpad is not only bigger but
despite being thinner the touchscreen
opal being thin and we actually have
more travel for the click so that's
something you definitely not expect
right you would think that for a thinner
laptop then there's less travel on the
touchpad or maybe no travel at all and
it's just a simulated hectic defect but
no it's really actually loose and it
travels more than previous year
[Music]
the keyboard overall
a volume then in 2022 but the feeling is
actually really nice there is a slight
reduction in key travel we have the
keywords here you can try side by side
but the new one feels really nice
considering that this is one of the
thinnest laptops on the market you'll be
surprised how well it actually feels to
type on it's so comfortable to type
object
and I O ports that's where there are a
lot of laptops on the market that are
much thicker and much heavier and they
only have type c ports and maybe maybe
just one or just two and that's it we
not only have a headphone jack but we
have full size HDMI cord and we have two
type-c foundable ports both of which can
output a video signal and they can
charge and they can be used at full
speed foundable as well
and the battery the battery is thinner
and it's actually slightly smaller in
capacity but it's almost the same as
previous as the previous gem from last
year and the battery life despite it
being an OLED display it's able to get
to 14 hours video playback and 12 hours
of web browsing which is outstanding for
such a thick and light 13 inch overboard
all right so we have portability that's
one of the Milestones or one of the the
pillars of our sandbox next up
sustainable what's uh what's
the sustainable highlight for the
Zenbook s13
all right
so there are six main points for
sustainability uh purposeful Innovation
means that we try to really focus on
things that end users really perceive as
an improvement as opposed to just having
something on the packaging or on the
product page that doesn't really impact
how they use their products upcycling is
using materials and reusing materials
and making some uh you know making some
extra value and creating some extra
value out of recycled materials
Packaging we did
we did some with ar animations there's a
slide about it later transparency we're
very open about how we do things who we
work with and what our goals are we have
a website where we have
um like I think a 10 or 15 year plan
that's our vision for sustainability is
we're very open about this and
responsible manufacturing which vendors
we choose to work with and carbon
neutrality so that's something that we
started with our commercial laptops and
we're now doing with the Zenbook s13 as
well the example August 13 is the first
Zen book that's going to be carbon
neutral where we actually purchase the
amount of carbon uh that it costs to
manufacture the laptop and create all
the materials and the assets so
um when you buy example s13 it's
completely offset you're not putting any
extra pressure on the environment
okay
all right so um there's a lot of parts
where we use recycled materials so for
example the chassis cover a lot of case
50 of the aluminum is recycled so that's
essentially when you see and see
aluminum you have all those shavings and
small bits of pieces
um instead of that being uh you know
used as trash essentially we use that
and recycle it to manufacture a really
premium high-end product as you'll see
the plasma ceramic aluminum is is a
really impressive new material very
sturdy feels very nice and looks very
nice and not at all like something you
would expect from something that's
recycled
um the the ease of aluminum all is an
alloy the same thing so we use the
shavings that other manufacturers use
when they see and see this material and
we reuse it instead of using brand new
material and for the keycaps 50 is
recycled Plastics the speakers use five
percent ocean valve and 45 recycled
Plastics and the BCD and touch fat are
halogen free
all right here we go from the details
um I think we can go through those
slides a little bit faster so you can
get a copy of the stack for all this
material if you want to use some of
these assets
um but I think we don't need to go for
all the details right now ocean down
plastic you guys will know what it means
and yeah so here you can see despite
using all these recycled materials that
does not mean that the quality of the
product is inferior in any way like some
people associate recycled with inferior
quality and it's true for some products
but for us if you go to the next slide
we can see we actually increased the
number of military grade tests that we
do for example of s13 it's 26 tests and
that includes drop tests high
temperature low temperature humidity
vibration tests all of these things to
make sure that using all these materials
the laptop is not as sturdy as the
previous one but even sturdier so that's
something that's really important
packaging yeah so this is what it looks
like and we have an AR animation when
you buy the products or even when you're
just a window shopping and you go
through the shop you can use your phone
scan a QR code and you get this kind of
Animation the reason we're doing that is
because we want to make the shopping and
unboxing experience still fun and
engaging
um despite not using all the different
color materials for printing on it which
is not good for the environment
okay and parts of the packaging can also
be
review so this part of the packaging can
be used as a laptop stand so if you
don't have a laptop stand yet or you're
not sure if you want to get one this is
something that you can use
in that idea of